[Music]
in summer 2018 the RAND Corporation
issued a massive study of the Gates
Foundation's ambitious half billion
dollar effective teacher initiative the
findings mostly negative ran concluded
that the initiative failed to make a
dent and student achievement or to
improve teacher quality the evaluation
teaches some useful lessons one the
systems were too time-consuming and the
paperwork too burdensome reforms tend to
fail they redirect time from students in
learning to even with the new systems in
place principals continue to inflate
teacher scores because it minimized
their hassles and the reforms did
nothing to change that three school
systems were reluctant to meaningfully
rethink teacher pay now this doesn't
mean we should give up on teacher
evaluation but it does mean that
reforming it is much more difficult than
many once anticipated the challenge
turns out to be less a willingness to do
it than the ability to do it well and
that's the lesson worth learning how do
you think we should evaluate teachers
let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI